navy says it's charting a
new course after rash of problems this
is a very interesting story
because it's six because it also has to
do with china
and how china's navy is slowly becoming
very very strong so navy says as
charting a new course after russia
promise this is a fox news story
embarrassing photos of rusty ships
online have
underscored delays in maintaining
warships made worse by the pandemic the
navy's trouble have caused delays and
costs of billions of billions of dollars
they come as tensions are grown in south
china sea
russia's navy is emboldened iranian
speed boats are harassing vessels in a
persian gulf
the navy fleet currently falls shy of
300 ships despite a
stated goal of 355 ships the chinese
fleet now outnumbers
the us navy let me say that one more
time the chinese fleet officially
outnumbers the us navy and the most
expensive ship
in the navy history meanwhile is the
newest aircraft carrier the uss gerald
ford
it has had problems with the system that
launches jets and the elevators that
moves weapons amongst other things it
was supposed to cost 10 and a half
billion dollars but the price tag
has risen to 13.3 billion dollars and
four weapon elevators are still not
finished and the reliability of key
systems is low says republican senator
jim
uh chairman and ranking member of the
armed service committee what do you
think about this with china
i'd say on the surface this is very
embarrassing yeah this isn't like a
a a headline where you're like uh yeah
this is great congratulations
this is actually embarrassing but this
will go back to your initial point of
maybe it's time to update
the type of warfare that we're investing
in right you talked about that we have
800
military military bases around the world
china has one in my favorite city in the
world
that booty my bad
and the maybe just maybe it's time for
us to take a
step back and realize all right maybe we
don't need all this maybe we need to
reinvest and allocate that money into
something a little more modern
rather than your typical traditional
assets so maybe this is a pause and
reset
for the us navy just maybe you know the
one thing that steps out for me
that scares me a little bit you know
usually i want to get too caught up
because you know
they have more they have a billion
people they're going to have more
military members than we do just sheer
numbers but
is it the whatever is going on off the
coast of japan
in that area where there's a very very
volatile area with the islands that
they're going to be
eventually tussling over that's south
china yeah everybody has to take that
very very seriously so if you're talking
about the chinese navy
i immediately go to that and there's a
legitimate threat there so
you know is it going to be a submarine
battle is it going to be two warships
going at it probably not
you know the war will be fought
differently but that's a that's an area
that kind of scares me so if you're
talking about the navy
and their dominance and the importance
that china's putting into it i think of
that region because we can't agree on
anything we just fight amongst ourselves
in this country
china knows exactly who their enemy is
every single day
i agree as being being an army guy do
you have any thoughts on the navy or
i think i think i look at china as being
so strategic
that i ask myself why what is china
doing investing in the navy
like why are they having so many fleets
what what for
is it because you know uh the
surrounding nations is it because
of in case some things happens at suez
canal is it because
u.s has ships out there and they're not
comfortable about it is it
what's their motive why ships so because
you know when you when you're
uh say you're playing a video game and
so one guy and you know how you
go out there and you're playing one of
those race games right and it says
you have this much money do you want to
invest it into a nicer car into turbo
into
a better suspension into better tires
and to better whatever right so you buy
turbo and all of a sudden a guy comes in
who's a 10 time champion whatever and he
buys
wheels you're like why wheels well he's
buying wheels for a reason because
wheels
if you get better let's just say tires
it's going to stick better so you're
going to have better handling while you
may have turbo
and you may crash but i'm gonna have
better in the turns so there's a reason
why he's picking so i'm
i'm trying to see why is china investing
so much money in their navy
if they're doing it there's got to be a
reason they're they're very methodical
in what they do they don't just invest
into anything
look at the military base they have one
foreign military base around the world
what for they're sitting there saying we
can use that money
for military base better by doing it in
a
different way so if they're putting it
into navy and u.s is sitting there
falling behind china
there's got to be something let me ask
you a question yeah
obviously we talk about china a lot on
the show i mean this is something we
talk about and everything that's going
on
and hey you better watch out hey you
better watch out china's doing this
china's beating us in this better watch
out freaking china
in your opinion what did china's
achilles heel at this point what are
they not seeing what are they slipping
on
that you want me to give you my yeah
your opinion if the world unites
china's in trouble i think that's their
achilles heel if the world unites
china's in trouble
if the world realizes they don't if the
world finds a different place to produce
chips if the world produ
finds a different place to produce the
80 percent of pharmaceutical if the
world finds a different place to produce
the ac
the everything that they produce over
there if the world realizes they don't
need china and that shifts from china to
india china's screwed yeah by the way
india has more resources more natural
resources india has the same amount of
people give or take 100 million less
india is the education is getting better
with the engineers that produce them
with the tech with the direction they're
going into
india's got a lot of stuff now obviously
they're a decade behind china maybe even
two decades behind china and they don't
have the same
infrastructure maybe not two decades but
they don't have the infrastructure that
china has
but if all of a sudden the world gets
behind india instead of getting behind
china
i don't think china is going to be happy
i think secretly china's afraid of the
world uniting and china's afraid of the
world leaning
and giving the business to india instead
of giving it to china i don't think they
like that
i agree with you i think the threat for
china is within and it's all about the
economy
and you know china is ahead of india
right now because they stole all our
secrets i mean that was part of their
strategy they
look at what we do and they copy it i
think we could help
india close that gap pretty quickly like
if we collaborated with them with our
breath
our best and brightest and you know help
them advance technology
you know with everything that they're
doing look and they have a much
much more progressive leader in that
country that's uh an ally of ours so
modi you're saying yeah yeah but listen
that's what i would say i think they
if the if they think that for a second
the world is looking at india
and break doing deals with india they're
they're not happy about it
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye